oh I'm playing not Musa who's like the
world renowned Kung Fu chess player
so okay this will be interesting I feel
like Misha has also been Misha is
probably the highest rated player I've
ever played in Duck chess too
um because most players are like still
provisional
okay I still have to remember how this
game works
E6
I think we'll stick with maybe I should
have played duck D3
to prevent D4
I'm actually curious about this line
quack is Gambit
the duck
maybe I should not have played that
maybe I'll play this
interesting move preventing Pawn E5
oh
yeah that's actually kind of annoying oh
no my duck
play this and then
this
so okay it looks like both of us are
going to be preventing each other's
bishops from developing
so maybe we'll both go for like some
fiend cattle
welcome back I'm pink therefore I'm spam
are you the world top duck chess
streamer
Maybe
I'm not the top rated player I think
there's some players above me
I mean I've only been playing I only
learned how to play this game a few days
ago so
I don't have so much experience
uh
uh how to do this
I think this is
she I don't know
oh E5 is coming next
interesting
okay so I put the duck on D5 so that
when E5 is played I can be guaranteed to
move to D5
opponent taking time
so we're we're playing the default time
control which is five plus four
and there's four second increment
because usually the sum
like it takes extra time to to play a
move so you have to move a piece and
then move the duck
thank you Andrew gifting to 25k
Oppo Pat
yeah this is kind of annoying let's play
this and this
ooh
hmm
okay so hitting a pawn
oh wow
oh that's a fancy move I can play
I can play this and this
so I'm saving my night
I mean this is scary though because the
bishop is aligned with my queen but the
duck saves me
I'm very grateful for this duck
oh I have something cool to share too
I
I can't even really explain what it is
if I have something cool to share after
this game which
um
hopefully I won't forget
can I take the pawn now
I take the pawn
the problem is Queen C1 duck B3
ah but then maybe it's okay
this is super risky
this may have just been a poison bomb as
my Rook might get trapped
but it's interesting
oh duck B4 I didn't see that
oh no I'm in trouble
and I played D4
I need D4
and then duck I gotta save my queen too
I mean there's there's multiple problems
for me here
I'm trying to create some confusion
though
oh that didn't really help
uh maybe a five
so F5 is interesting
and then duck
preventing preventing ampluson
oh no
I got smothered duck needed
someone call an ambulance
I got attacked by a duck and a knight
oh no
I feel so broken
[Music]
I could resign but I could also
just die a sad tragic
death
oh that was like a giga duck
okay I have something interesting to
share so there's this tool that
generates
um it generates images based on words
that you feed it
and
it's called mid-journey bot I think
there's there's a few others there's
like dolly
but I've I've been using mid-journey
and I fed it a prompt The Prompt was
of something like
large muscular duck
with dramatic lighting
and it generated this image
so maybe I'll use this image for a
thumbnail
but then I also I gave it a prompt
um duck chess
it's really cool like it just generates
this from scratch based off the words
that you give it and it generated this
so these images are slightly horrifying
but I think they would be cool for
YouTube thumbnails